ed as a producer on this i mean how did
you get involved with turning this
australian series into a series here
what made you
want to be a part of this
um
so all right you have a little more
background than most that's uh the
australian show
um i happened to see it i loved it um
hamish and andy i think are brilliant
and
um
and and i just
what i loved was how was just seeing the
human connection
in the studio when they're telling these
stories and
and they're listening to the stories
that the reenactments are almost like a
bonus they're just this really fun epic
additional layer
um
and
i when the opportunity arose to
to bring it to the states and um
turn it into a show it just seemed like
uh
randall park is the ideal co-host
and uh and and it it has been as much
fun as i hoped like it has just been an
absolute blast to make this show so in
other words then randall you didn't lose
a bet and get forced into this pairing
somehow
oh no no i i i i was unfamiliar with the
uh australian show
but uh when when i got a call from ed
and his team to to to be a part of it i
i watched as many episodes of the
australian version as i uh as i could
and and i was blown away by you know
just the
the heart the heart in in a lot of these
stories and uh and so just the thought
of being able to sit down with ed who
i've been a fan of and just loved for so
long uh to to just hang out with him and
listen to these
incredible stories from from all these
different people it just was like such a
no-brainer for me i was like i'm in
since you guys really are in the same
room for this you're sitting in chairs
in front of whoever is telling the story
how much thought went into things like
what the room would look like what would
be behind you what the chairs would be
the jackets that you're wearing i mean
what was there a lot of conversation
about all of that
so yeah the answer is yes there was a
there was a lot of
thought that went into the production
design and even our wardrobe uh on the
show where we wear these
velvet blazers um
and uh
and and and really the intention was to
kind of honor the story and honor the
connection that we wanted to build uh in
that space and
um and so there's uh there's
there's sort of it's sort of like a
formal setting in a way but but the
um but the production design is inviting
like a living room or a library like it
just feels
like uh something that
a place where you want to sit and
hear
some some stirring narratives and uh
so we wanted it to feel cozy uh too and
um
and it's just it's about listening for
us yeah it's really about
about kind of getting
the juicy bits of these stories out of
people yeah on our blazers if you look
closely there's like an insignia
on the pocket with like an ear
an ear
design on it it's just basically because
you know these jackets are our listening
jackets we are here to listen and to
and to uh uh to take what you're sharing
you know and uh and that kind of
formality and that uh elevating these
stories from these just everyday people
is a you know it's just this great great
gift not just for them but for us
we hear that a big part of acting is
reacting so i mean could you ever have
imagined that this is how you would use
those acting skills and what did you
take from getting to really experience
these stories with these people
gosh i mean i didn't even look at it as
acting exactly yeah
this was yeah i wouldn't call this uh
none of my acting muscles were at work
here this was it's just
it's just being in the space with these
storytellers yeah and and i i'm not sure
if if we made this clear before but
when we sit down with these storytellers
randall and i have never heard the story
we've never even met the storyteller so
it's all fresh and brand new and that
keeps us on the edge of our seat it
keeps us excited to hear what's next and
engaged and i think that really comes
across like the
the kind of honesty and spontaneity of
the interaction
um
is part of what's so fun about it
so are you then not having to do retakes
either so that you have to act surprised
the third time you hear the same part of
the story never no
no it's just literally just sitting down
no that they tell the story once yeah um
you know there may be
moments what
you know as
we're listening to the story uh
and kind of always digging for more
clarity throughout the
uh the process
um
and so what you're what you wind up
seeing is actually a very condensed cut
down version because
because we go on a lot we ask a lot of
questions
yeah and we asked you know we
for uh you know just kind of yeah more
clarity and and and sometimes
more uh to visualize the setting better
oh tell us tell us a little bit more
about that place so tell us a little bit
more about uh that person what do they
look like you know and uh and so
that's just our it's questions we'd have
maybe we'll release like the unedited
versions as a podcast or something i
mean you can't like some of these
stories are so rich and detailed and
complex in ways that that we just didn't
have the time to get into in the in the
show
um i mean the what we wound up with is
still
amazing
but but i mean there's just so many
layers to these things yeah
and i loved another series he recently
did rutherford falls i thought that was
also a lot of fun really unexpected show
what was it like to hear the reaction to
that show and what are you looking
forward to about season two
um thank you for for saying that i i am
so so proud uh to be a part of this show
to be a part of rutherford falls um
i've been really overwhelmed by the the
response to the show i i think uh
you know we just
set out to make something that was
really really funny and also um
uh kind of honest about some
some tricky issues and uh
uh and
we had a ton of fun doing it
i think uh
season two is
we i'm we're actually shooting season
two right now um i came from set to be
here
and uh
it's
bonkers
it's uh
all i can say is go
go binge season one right now because
you're going to want to be all caught up
to jump into season two it's uh
it's gonna be a blast
randall as someone who worked at a
blockbuster i i'm very curious about the
series you're doing set at blockbuster i
mean what made you want to do that what
can we expect from that i worked in one
of the music stores not the video side
but oh i worked at a blockbuster that's
right i you know i never worked at a
blockbuster i was a member i had i had
the card but i i did work in a video
store
uh out of high school so uh
so i i have a lot of fond memories of
that time and uh uh and i miss going to
the blockbuster and just kind of
looking at boxes you know these these
movies and flipping through them i could
spend hours doing that and uh so when
the the project came to me uh you know i
read the script i saw the people
involved and and it just seemed like
such a fun
fun show to be a part of so so right now
we're gearing up to start uh shooting
we're we're still casting and it's it's
all coming together uh but i'm very
excited
well it seems like for this there are
endless people with endless stories so
are you hoping to do more episodes of
this show i will be honest with you
i hope that we are doing this show for
the next 20 years i
love this show so much
uh and it's it's so fun i mean it's
really kind of like
it's barely work yeah like randall and i
get to just show up and sit down with
these amazing hilarious or
you know poignant or people and just
get into some really fun stuff
yeah there's no there's no better gig
there's no better it's just it's just uh
uh
uh
yeah i i i also hope it keeps going i
mean just uh
there's so many stories you know i mean
as we've learned just from shooting this
first season there's just so many
stories and and
and
even people who are the most unassuming
people you sit them on that couch
and they start telling their story and
it's just
you're just in it you're just in it and
they become the most fascinating people
and uh so there's an endless well of uh
of really great stories because we all
have
yeah those
those wild stories from you know
experiences and and things to share and
so yeah i just i i just would just love
to hear more to keep hearing more
yeah i mean i've only seen the first two
episodes but it feels like the living
embodiment of truth is stranger than
fiction and that you should never judge
a book by its cover because yeah right
both things seem true with both of the
episodes that i saw
yeah
yeah i think uh to randall's point like
we all have these stories and that's why
when people
make themselves vulnerable enough to
share them it's there's such a strong
connection there and i like we felt
connected to each and every storyteller
i think audiences will also feel that
connection
and laugh and cry and you know just be
excited with with
with every
with each story
it's
yeah it's a ton of fun yeah yeah i love
just having the reaction i mean i kept
saying like no way that can't happen or
oh my god i can't believe you know it's
just
you keep wanting to talk to the screen
so i thought that was it was really fun
oh great
awesome
thanks you guys i appreciate you talking
to me about it it was delightful so oh
i'm so glad yeah thank you thank you
thanks a lot